Well,
hello, how are you? You leave for me or
because of your report today, Monday,
February 22. Teachers and
school administrative staff are preparing to
welcome
students in person next week, as
is the case at the elementary school where
role which already assigns desks for
its students under the letters a and b in addition
to other signs to maintain
social distancing
on the other hand clark county seeks to
hire 600 employees to
assist in the crosswalk for
students returning to schools
must be  over 18 to apply for this
job position and pass a
background check wage is $15
per hour for more information
visit our online page
drink your tequila some lemon juice
because today is national
margarita day la margarita  it became popular
due to its prohibition when many from
here traveled to mexico to buy
alcohol today the link and the se  s astra de
celebrates on this special day that awaits
salt and tomato a margarita or two now
we pass with the weather forecast
temperatures will increase for the
beginning of the week the maximum today
will be 68 degrees and minimum in the
40s have a good day  I am sal y
jaramillo and this was news now in Spanish
[Music]